hi everyone I'm Ilana it's games from
day one and I just finished playing
project spa now I initially saw it at e3
and was like yeah the game looks pretty
cool but I wonder what the limits off
and then I played it myself and it's
just blown my mind I'm here with one of
the creative geniuses behind project
Spock tell me about your game so project
spark is a game where you can
essentially create games it's an
open-world digital canvas where we give
people the tools to create and paint
terrain as well as create different
gameplay mechanics they can create
everything from a first-person shooter
to a 2d side-scroller
if you can imagine it it can probably be
made in projects part
so with projects buck I know that you
can paint the terrains you can make
things look different that you can also
spawn environments yeah so as far as
spotting the environments right now we
have a forest and Arctic and a desert
biome and if you were to paint using
those brushes what it does is doesn't
just paint the terrain it also drops
little things like trees rocks if you're
using forest arctic it would drop like
glaciers and icebergs and ice floes and
for desert cactus and so we have these
environments we're going to be releasing
a sci-fi galaxies pack soon will come
with like a starry space sky it'll drop
little like gas globes so the idea is to
release content that's going to enable
you people to create any kind of
environment and you kind of like
ambiance of a
beyond the environments obviously you
can change kind of AI you can change
behaviors of everything in the game so
what are the limits to that we haven't
really seen any yet you can really take
any object in the game and using the
code which is our simple scripting
language in project spark create any
game mechanic and make it behave any way
you want you could make a house
something that follows you in tumbles
around you could throw a squirrel and
have the squirrel fly around and
manipulate the terrain as you're playing
so obviously it's in beta right now what
have you seen people make with some of
the coolest stuff people have made
there's been a few really amazing
recreations of some existing games like
titanfall I think the one that impressed
me most was a very story driven and had
a unique art style as a 2d
side-scrolling platformer that was
completely black and white very
primitive shapes but it just drew me and
it was very addictive and that's the
biggest I think that's the most
important thing is that they're not just
games that are being made they're games
you want to play so you say it's story
focused yes how can you put a story into
projects box yeah so it's a good
question we we offer a few different
methods and gameplay mechanics to do
that you can letterbox the screen you
can have different objects and
characters speak you can record voice
using the Kinect device and have
different characters and objects speak
using your voice you can also use the
Kinect to record animations and then
and objects
so how big actually all the world is
they're like map size there is and as
you're playing it on Xbox one or Windows
we show the limitations of what you can
drop so you'll see that you're kind of
approaching the limit but we have a
feature known as level linking which
allows you to create multiple worlds and
link them together so if you were
creating like any video game you can
jump from one level exactly if you think
of MMOs that have like instances you
could build an experience like that by
walking through an instance and having
that link to another world that you
create so I could make like a 12-hour
game with a bunch of different levels
that's right yeah this is I just can't
even comprehend how big project Spock is
it's it's going yeah it's it's huge we
have over a million creators right now
we're getting about seven hundred levels
created a day and every single day I'm
just stunned that they've done what
they've done that they've they've used
our tools in ways that we didn't think
possible and that's really inspiring
you're someone working on papers I'm
pretty excited to see that stuff so what
is the game actually coming out so it
will be on shelves October 10th in
Europe and then will be on shelves
October 7th in the US cool thanks very
much yeah thank you